alec castonguay à montréal emmanuelle
latraverse détail tobiko en ontario
michel ces objets à montréal bonsoir à
vous trois bonsoir il reste deux
semaines mais turin il reste deux
cheminots comme quoi même les plus longs
marathons
un jour on voit la ligne d'arrivée et ça
bouge on va parler des sondages à la
toute fin mais revenons sur la nouvelle
majeure de la journée ce partenariat
transpacifique une large zone de
libre-échange donc en préparation tout
ça doit être voté dans tous les
parlements
je vous entends de chacun d'entre vous à
qui ça fait le plus la ferme soir peu
étaient très contents de l'annoncé
aujourd'hui
alec castonguay je pense que ça fait là
faire de stephen harper et ça fait la
sphère de thomas manqué au npd
les deux peuvent prendre des positions
bien tranchées dans ce dossier-là
stephen harper en disant écoutez nous
commerce international c'est important
on ouvre les frontières du canada au
marché asiatique entre autres qui est un
marché prometteur qui est important et
donc des gagnants dans cette entente le
évidemment stephen harper va mettre
l'accent sur les gagnants mais aussi des
perdants dans cette entente là il ya du
grain à moudre pour le npd
quand on a vu notamment l'industrie
automobile qui était inquiète qui
pourrait perdre jusqu'à 20000 emplois
pour les pièces l'industrie agricole le
lait le volailles les yeux qu'un médecin
sans frontières sort en disant c'est une
très mauvaise entente parce que ça va
faire bondir le prix des médicaments
tout ce sont des alliés naturels le du
npd ça peut certainement aider thomas
moteur dans le cadre de sa campagne du
grain à moudre le parce que des enfants
c'est pas un accord comme on en a eu
avec l'union européenne la corée du sud
ou même les etats-unis jodie pays
dans cet accord le qui ont pas les mêmes
normes environnementales que pas les
mêmes normes pour les travailleurs que
pour le même type de salaire qu'on pense
au vietnam au brunéi à la malaisie
offrir ou donc il ya des inquiétudes le
qui peuvent surgir dans un débat comme
celui qui avait par exemple avec un
accord comme l'union européenne et ça
permet et ça permet manuel j'imagine à
thomas mulcair de reparler à sa
clientèle un naturel qui s'inquiètent de
ce genre de partenariat économique de
libre échange
oui mais c'est un couteau à double
tranchant ça pour thomas mika c'est sûr
que lui s'est campé dans la position
contre il faut protéger
industrie laitière protéger l'industrie
automobile c'est un message qui trouve
écho dans les comtés au québec le npd
doit vouloir protéger et ce qu'il veut
gagner dans le sud ouest ontarien et
c'est sûr que pour un chef de parti de
gauche qui est en perte de vitesse c'est
important de protéger sa base et ça
c'est le message que la base militante
du npd veut entendre
mais en même temps pour un chef de parti
qui veut convaincre les canadiens que le
npd s'est pas risqué c'est aussi à
double tranchant c'est ce pourquoi il ya
des aspects du discours de monsieur
mulcair sur le partenariat
transpacifique est un peu équivoque en
disant moi j'ai pas contre le
libre-échange mais je suis contre les
aspects de cette de cette entente là
pour pouvoir le réouvrir ou pas donc
c'est aussi un terrain un peu glissant
pour monsieur michel envoyait monsieur a
un peu ce matin conférence de presse
comptant puis il a fait des détours même
pour parler beaucoup en français pour
que son message résonne aussi au québec
où il ya des craintes pour les
producteurs laitiers notamment mais pour
lui une bonne affaire non gomis une
bonne affaire parce qu'il faut pas
oublier une chose malgré tout ce qui a
été dit sur les accords de libre-échange
commençons à 88 avec la carte les états
unis le canton n'est fait c'est la
frontière à la fin toutes les peurs qui
ont été des grosses peur qu'on dise dans
les accords de libre échange ne se sont
pas matérialisées on n'est pas devenu
51e état des états unis on n'a pas perdu
l'assurance santé oms a oui on a perdu
le courrier à domicile n'est ce pas
cause de ça mais vous savez alors plus
le temps passe et plus on arrive avec un
nouveau un nouvel accord comme celui là
est ce qu'on peut vraiment dire vous
savez nous on va on va laisser passer ce
train là et dans les wagons de ce train
là il ya le commerce et les états unis
il ya le commerce avec le japon bien le
commerce éventuellement avec la chine
évidemment qu'on peut pas faire ça chez
eux après le sait très bien
alors il peut y avoir des réserves et il
peut y avoir des gagnants et des
perdants mais à un moment donné dans le
grand ensemble des choses normalement
les accords de libre échange ont été des
bonnes choses pour le canada pis pour le
québec en particulier et pour le lait et
pour la volailles et les oeufs on ouvre
un peu mais on ne jette pas inter toute
cette protection parce qu'on protège ou
trois produits là c'est beaucoup moins
qu'on a qu'on a compensé un moment donné
chiffre qui circulait sur le pourcentage
de l'américain qui allait pouvoir
rentrer se disent pour sa 10e 2 3 5 ce
n'est pas une arme comme c'est énorme
différence n'est peut-être pas oui bien
sûr pour un producteur ne laisse pas une
bonne idée mais c'est quand même parce
qu'on annonçait la semaine dernière donc
il n'ya pas de manchette lannion qui dit
on tue la gestion de l'offre sa
référence ou si un passeur c'est quand
même des choses que monsieur monsieur
rappelons que peut négocier et avec j'ai
demandé au président des producteurs de
lait du québec est ce que les prix ne
risque pas de baisser pour le lin parce
que l on paie le lait plus cher au
québec faut le dire là soyons clair
quand même ayant un prix à payer pour
tout seul cette protection qui est bien
peut-être et un prix à payer
donc ce précieux tous les consommateurs
vont se jeter vont déchirer leur chemise
donc plus d'abord on peut pas le même
père au québec et dans d'autres
provinces pourtant c'est le même
programme de gestion de l'offre est déjà
des anomalies en ontario qui est pas mal
moins cher qu'au québec
déjà si on pouvait régler ça serait ça
serait assez vient au québec ensuite
écouté la plupart de ces pays le
subventionnent de manière très
importante leur agriculture au québec et
au canada on fonctionne d'une manière
différente on règlement que l'offre et
la demande avec des quotas mais en bout
de piste quand le japon vers 10
milliards de dollars à ses agriculteurs
c'est quand même le gouvernement qui
verse cet argent l'os si ça vient pas
directement à l'achat des produits
c'est quand même l'argent que le
gouvernement ne peut pas mettre ailleurs
donc un coût pour les contribuables
d'une manière ou d'une autre ou bien on
subventionne l'agriculture et on met
d'argent là dedans plutôt que les mains
des programmes sociaux ou bien on laisse
les gens payés en dollars et demi de
dollars de plus leur pain de lait dans
d'une manière ou d'une autre lot en bout
de piste les contribuables paient que de
toute manière un peu plus cher pour
protéger leur agriculture nationale très
bien c'est fait
emmanuel on voit l'autobus de justin
trudeau derrière vous c'était
aujourd'hui le programme du parti
libéral dévoilé mais en fait il a été
dévoilé en petites pièces là on n'a fait
que faire une synthèse dont oui il ya
des nouveaux éléments dans cette danse
est plate forme et le fait que le parti
libéral est décidé d'aller de l'avant
aujourd'hui malgré tout l'ampleur des
nouvelles
le souci à quel point
juste un être doux lui veut rester en
marge de ce débat sur le partenariat
transpacifique qui compte à écouter ses
points de presse depuis deux jours et
dit je suis pro commerce à chaque deux
phrases justement pour rassurer les
électeurs à ce chapitre là donc c'est un
vaste programme libéral c'est peut-être
pas le livre rouge michel pour faire les
comparaisons mais 80 de cette page 104
promesses
donc on se demande des fois si le
participant très de s'éparpiller parce
que vraiment tout le monde y trouve son
compte là dessus il ya bien sûr les
baisses d'impôts pour la classe moyenne
la subvention pour les enfants les
infrastructures mais dans ces 60
milliards de dollars pour les
infrastructures
on met vraiment de tout le transport en
commun mais de l'argent pour le logement
social de l'argent aussi pour des foyers
pour les femmes battues et cetera chef
libéral lui il entre à la priorité crée
de l'emploi créé créer de l'emploi créé
la croissance et protéger la classe
moyenne un mot messieurs sur ce
programme dévoilé je vous parlais des
sondages après mais là on a toujours nos
rues tout tout tout dans le programme
libéral ce qui maintient qui n'avait pas
été annoncée aujourd'hui ça des bourses
pour des étudiants chablais qui avaient
des juridictions provinciales ceci notre
histoire et on va réglementer vous le
saurez comptable de savoir patrice le
gras trans et le sel dans les aliments
encore au début de la campagne où
souvent on disait qu'il y avait des
micros projets ce qui se faisait
je me dis qu'on finit par les micros
promet sans doute les labos ne riez pas
michel du gras trans et du sel non non
je rigole ce soir et je vais vous
dévoiler un secret ça devrait ça devait
être une question au débat parce que les
américains sont plus sévères que nous
pour réglementer ce genre de chose on
allait demander est ce qu'on vit pas
dans un pays où si le laisser faire on
laisse les entreprises réglementées elle
même alors joie que les libéraux cette
promesse là on a dû éliminer est la
question que vous avez matrice ils iront
en europe donc tous ok alec son ajoint
on veut le voir les justin trudeau
justement les libéraux qui creusent leur
écart c'est le nano ce quotidien
libero à 35,6 parti conservateur en
deuxième à 31 pilotes [ __ ] quand même loin
derrière à 23%
donc monsieur trudeau se dit l'a63
quatre bonnes journées encore comme ça
et peut-être que je deviendrais premier
ministre ou quoi moi je suis sceptique
patrice étant donné que la noce et qui
est une très bonne firme de sondage pour
le dire est un peu tout seul dans son
coin actuellement avec ces chiffres là
sur les sept maisons de sondages qui
font du sondage régulièrement depuis le
début de la campagne en a quatre qui met
encore les conservateurs en avance et
aucun ne me les libéraux en avance par
quatre points comme danas et personne
certainement nommé le npd à 22 heures la
plupart du temps on est dans une
pratique entre 25 et 29 % pour le npd
donc ça ne veut pas dire qu'il a tort il
est peut-être en train de voir quelque
chose que les autres sondeurs n'ont pas
vu encore qu'ils vont éventuellement
rattraper mais ça se peut aussi qu'il ya
des corrections qu'ils se fassent en
cours de route parce que l'on est dans
un bon écart de quatre points d'avance
des libéraux sur les conservateurs alors
j'ai redouté dont alors que d'autres
sondages qui met quatre points d'avance
des conservateurs sur les libéraux là
c'est quand même assez différent d'une
journée à l'autre
alors faut juste faire attention aux
chiffres ses claques les libéraux ont
une assez bonne campagne jusqu'à présent
ce qui sont en avance
on ne le sait pas qui sont en avance à
ce point là c'est encore plus difficile
à dire emmanuelle et michel on va
conclure là dessus mais c'est un peu le
cauchemar pour les firmes de sondage
cette campagne très serré très il faut
aller dans les micros endroits poussent
à une maison de sondage national c'est
plus difficile à faire emmanuelle et
michel ensuite oui ces essais des micros
course il faut comprendre moi je suis
ici dans la banlieue de toronto est au
big o ça c'est le genre de kotick est
contre les libéraux et les conservateurs
c'est la lutte est très très chaude
entre les deux une quarantaine de
compter comme ça dans la ceinture de
toronto est ce que les stratèges de part
et d'autre nous disent c'est que le
problème c'est qu'un une journée eux
sont en avance sur les si les
conservateurs une journée libéraux une
journée conservateur alors comment est
ce qu'on est capable d'avoir un portrait
précis en ce moment là dessus c'est
assez difficile sur un peu tout le monde
le concept du moins sur le terrain
nana s'appelle une journée l'autre ferme
appel le lendemain
voilà c'est fait une chaise extrêmement
fait d'où l'intérêt de ce qui va arriver
d'où l'intérêt mais faut pas oublier
quand il ya trois parties dans à peu
près dans les mêmes eaux
c'est très difficile de voir comment ça
ça va tomber dans les comtés à la fin à
la faim ce qui compte ce n'est pas le
vote populaire c'est le siège alors il
sait ce qu'il faut faire très attention
et je partage un petit peu le
scepticisme de mon ami alex sur les
sondages de monsieur la noce je parlais
des néo-démocrates ce matin qu'ils
écoutent la nos chiffres nous dit oui je
te dis pas que ça va bien mais on n'est
pas largué comme on est là c'est pas
vrai que ça va si mal que ça non plus et
j'entendais des consommateurs disent
faites attention c'est sûr ils ont pas
quatre points d'avance les libéraux
alors il faut faire une moyenne des
sondages en exactement
on verra bien pu manquer cette moyenne
de sondage donnent nous donne pas de
résultat dans dans presque 400 comptes
et au canada mais c'est fort juste que
vous êtes michel c'est ce n'est pas le
vote populaire mais c'est les batailles
circonscription par circonscription et
cette mathématique là bien malin celui
qui pourrait la prévoir à l'heure
actuelle
bref on est un peu à la case départ
pires de island puis n'oublions pas
combien que la grande avance on le dire
ou le npd au québec longtemps l'homme
est passé la grande avance des libéraux
dans les maritimes qui joue exactement
qui gonflent leur vote populaire à
l'échelle nationale messieurs dames
toujours plaisir à demain au revoir au
roi